Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono Favij oggi
siamo su The Midnight Man raga è un Indi
horror fatto con lo unite Engine che mi
avete consigliato in tantissimi c'è
veramente in troppi Eh praticamente
consiste nel Cioè io non ho capito
neanche sinceramente Comunque vabbè Eh
praticamente è un videogame basato
sull'uomo di mezzanotte dei Midnight Man
e non ho capito bene Siamo con una
candela la grafica è quella di pizza
Delivery ehm Allora c'è scritto 0000 Ok
perfetto Siamo a mezzanotte perfetto
ragazzi ci siamo eh Tra l'altro un
paesaggio fantastico in mezzo alla città
proprio la civiltà ragazzi Eh qua
Guardate Quanti semafori cazzo con te
macchine anche di notte Vabbè comunque
consiste nel cos'è questa roba Guarda
roba premi F per aprire io io ho aperto
queste mi si è aperta sotto va bene Mi
fa piacere Vabbè apriamo le porte a caso
ragazzi siamo in una casa Eh non so
perché mi avete consigliato di sto gioco
come vi sono veramente arrivate
tantissime richieste presumo che faccia
paura perché non lo so se no non
l'avreste scherzo perché voi volete bene
lo so io che mi volete bene ok non è
esattamente più visto programma Ma va
bene così è TV Slender cosa noi lasciamo
l'accesso tanto non la guarda nessuno eh
C'è un ufficio benissimo un ufficio
fantastico Io direi che chiamare
qualcuno non è una brutta idea vero No
devo entrare su Facebook ma questo
sarebbe un monitor A me sembra più una
scatola Vabbè comunque io entro su
Facebook nel dubbio vabbè allora siamo a
casa Ancora non abbiamo concluso una
mazza di niente e cioè bello sto bagno
fantastico Anzi si accende anche l'acqua
Wow c'era Porca [ __ ] cos'era e
[ __ ]
questa non me l'aspettavo Ecco lo sapevo
perché mi avete consigliato
chi cazzo era Frankenstein e bene Non ho
ben capito cosa è successo però è
apparso qualcuno è stato fantastico
cazzo Non vedo l'ora di tornarci lì
dentro eh vabbè allora devo devo
rientrarci per forza perché qualcosa ti
devo fare che già da una porta qui
Apriti non si è aperta Eh vabbè Allora
mettiamoci in un angolo così non ci
piglia la sprovvista bene allora non c'è
nessuno beh tra l'altro raga Questo è il
cesto più bello che io abbia mai visto
Eh direi di fare un bel bagno fantastico
eh uomo molto sexy Ti va di fare un
bagno con me sarai felicissimo Eh vabbè
noi leviamoci Io qua prima che torni
Sinceramente non ci tengo a rivederlo
chiude ehm il televisore del drone Tra
l'altro era acceso ma chi se ne porta
Allora qua c'è un'altra stanza da letto
e qual è raga Qual è lo scopo di
distruggere Cos'è che devo fare
precisamente Io vado al piano di sotto
perché non so che cosa devo
[Musica]
si è chiuso qualcosa da solo e non sono
stato io ma non voglio andare a
controllare io vado di Anzi no ci sono
cose che non ho visto un altro Madonna
ragazzi Sti cessi sono fantastici cioè
guardarli solo ti viene voglia di andare
a cagare fantastico eh apriamo anche
l'acqua pirata tanto per sprecare un
pochettino [ __ ] io esco prima che
compaia qualcuno lì dentro Io esco fa
cagare sto maledetto
Buongiorno senza buon nome molto tardi
perché non se ne torna a casa tranquilla
perché gli si è spenta la candela raga
eh eh Senta allora è tardissimo Sono in
mezzanotte e mezza è già passata
mezz'ora da prima così a caso
all'improvviso e quindi secondo me se
torna a casa è meglio perché sta lì
cazzo si faccia un tuffo in piscina buon
uomo faccia qualcosa ma si levi dai
[ __ ] c'è un'altra porta Ok perfetto
ho riacceso la la candela eh senta si
faccia i cazzi suoi Allora prego in
mezzanotte e mezza che vuole da me che
cazzo è successo che è caduta una sedia
Anzi son cadute le sedie merda no c'è il
fuoco Spegni cos'è Perché va tutto a
fuoco qui fermi un attimo eh cioè c'è
anche il frigo buono no porco cazzo è
che è vuoto maledizione Dov'è la mia
Nutella Eh mi serve Allora ragazzi cioè
c'è ancora lì è ancora lì non si fa la
gente quando si fissa sugli altri non
c'è verso Cioè ma qua c'è un'altra porta
forse
si è aperta veramente cioè io posso
scappare posso scappare fuori Oddio no
lo Scappo fuori Chiudi chiudi chiudi
chiudi chiudi Ok ok
ferma Oddio entrato Porca [ __ ] come è
entrato spiegatemi come ha fatto entrare
Raga non ha senso 'sto gioco Allora
ragazzi Abbiamo capito che io non
cos'era era una pastiglia per iniziare
cos'è che vola Ok ragazzi Oddio le sedie
le sedie tentano di uccidermi cosa sta
succedendo Eh vabbè Ragazzi ma perché
cazzo mi consigliate sti giochi che
senso c'hanno Eh vabbè allora sta
volando di tutto se volete volare
qualcos'altro Non lo so Allora allora
[Musica]
ragazzi sta diventando inquietante
ragazzi non è normale si aprono le porte
permesso e devo lavarmi le mani io ho
visto anche cagando addosso Quindi
magari una cappatina al cesso ce la
faccio Eh sentite cosa cosa devo fare
qui Qual è lo scopo di questo gioco
Scusate Qual è il mio obiettivo Ma posso
uscire di qua No veramente non uscirei
di qua anche volendo ehm Andiamo di qua
ancora non ci sono entrato qui dentro
bene forse devo accendere tutti i
televisori Ah no questa era già acceso
Eh Salve Eh no non è una non è buona
educazione spiare la gente da fuori che
è successo Cos'è
[Musica]
Allora Raga vi giuro che questo è
l'ultimo tentativo perché non ha senso
sto gioco perché mi avete consigliato
sta roba che mi ammazzano senza che io
faccia nulla allora io non so che cosa
devo fare precisamente ma voglio provare
ad accendere tutto il possibile tutto
anche lavandini tutto Voglio provare a
fare questo perché mi sembra L'unica
cosa che possa fare eh Perché tranne i
lavandini delle porte non posso fare
nient'altro quindi lo faccio Ok sta roba
che parte ancora non ho capito perché
non importa accendiamo qualsiasi anche
il fuoco vai anche il fuoco tutto anche
le sedie volate Ah veramente siete già
volate di vostro va bene così frigo
aperto bene tutto accendiamo anche il
microonde Vai a preparare prepariamoci
un panino già che ci siamo qualcuno di
voi al toast Ok grazie mille per avermi
aperto la porta Così ci metto di meno
vai ce la posso fare Sto aprendo di
tutto eh La lavatrice è anche la
lavatrice mi ci ficco pure dentro
volendo Eh sta parte da questa parte non
si apre Va bene questa porta è finta
devo quando si è aperta sta roba quando
si è aperta nuova Ma la devo tenere
aperta perché sennò non funziona Allora
anche sto televisore vai tutto accendo
qualsiasi cosa cosa manca l'altra stanza
Cioè posso fare raga ce la posso fare è
l'ultima l'ultima stanza è questa devo
accendere Ok perfetto Ci siamo acceso
tutto tranne forse sto televisore qui Sì
infatti questa è l'ultimo che manca okay
adesso ufficialmente ok Ha ufficialmente
stronzo Ecco che cos'è brutto bastardo
acceso tutto cosa vuoi ancora cosa devo
fare Raga io scappo No non so se è una
buona idea scappare sinceramente Va bene
io non lo faccio bene Ho acceso la
candela cosa devo fare sto gioco ragazzi
non ha senso allora l'acqua è accesa va
bene Ho acceso qualsiasi cosa non si può
chiamare qualcuno No vero non cioè Beh i
telefoni ci sono ma non li usiamo per
carità non si sa mai che riesco a
salvarmi ehm
qua è acceso Ragazzi io non so cosa devo
fare Vuoi farti un bagno non lo so
perché sto giro vagando come un
deficiente e la doccia si può accendere
non si può fare la doccia allora non so
bene sto cadendo sto facendo un casino
eh
Accenditi Accenditi si è spenta Ok
perfetto È caduto qualcosa sta cadendo
di tu Raga io non capisco cosa devo fare
sto facendo ho aperto ho aperto tutto
quello che c'era da aprire bene Ehi
senti sottospecie di Frankenstein
riuscito cosa dovrei fare Dimmelo tu e
che poi c'è l'entrata dall'altra parte
magari l'hai vista Porca [ __ ] lo
sapevo che l'aveva vista lo sapevo lo
sapevo
[ __ ]
Che stronzo Cioè io io l'ho pensato E
lui l'ha fatto Ho detto c'ho la porta
dietro aperta non la vede potrebbe fare
gira Infatti ha fatto il giro
maledizione Raga io non ci gioco più a
sta roba Ma cos'era Qual è lo scopo di
sto gioco parentesi Infatti Grazie
grazie mille Direi che posso chiuderla
qui perché è stata una cosa impensabile
Eh vabbè se se il video Vi è piaciuto e
se odiate anche questo stronzo mettete
un mi piace al video e anche la pagina
di Facebook come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione Se non siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo in
un prossimo video bella ragazzi